originale logo andere modell aber
original hätte der abfüll nicht
reingebissen tier her eigentlich ausgab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
heute mal wieder in gewohnt alter
position
viele von euch haben es wahrscheinlich
schon vermisst auch dass auch ein schild
muss man aber sagen dass er auf jeden
fall echten 30 schild oder ich lese
seitdem immer wieder kommentare dass das
schild
bevor ich mich immer drüber heute geht
es um apple produkte von riesch ich habe
ganz viel eingekauft damals in meinem
video ich würde sagen ich zeige euch mal
ganz kurz was ich alles gekauft habt wir
es wird schon kurz hin zu meinem
computer dann kann ich euch das wasser
zeigen und dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder muss gleich ja leute was geht
auch noch mal willkommen
von dieser position her ja ich wollte
euch kurz hier wie eben auch schon
wahrscheinlich gesagt mal die ganzen
produkte zeigen nicht bestellt hat um
die es heute gehen wird alles
apple-produkte irgendwelche apple fake
produkte ich habe eigentlich alles
gekauft was ich irgendwie von apple
gefunden habe außer ipad fällt mir
gerade ein aber wenn ich das auch noch
bestellen soll schreibt mal in die
kommentare
ich glaube aber das iphone 11 ist schon
mal am meisten dass ich euch sofort
zeigen werde
wir fangen wir an mit dieser smart watch
2020 new upgrade watch blablabla die
sieht ja auch ein bisschen aus wie apple
watch und ich habe sie auch direkt
gefunden als ich halt apple watch
eingegeben hat kann ich euch auch gern
noch mal hier zeigen ihr gebt einfach
apple watch ein und dann kommt direkt
diese uhr hier könnte schon hinkommen so
ein bisschen wird bin ich mal gespannt
was die taugt als nächstes haben wir
hier mini er war zwar okay das sind die
airports prodi habe ich sowieso schon
davon habe ich so viele dass ich mir
gedacht habe du musst du nicht noch mal
extra bestellen ich habe davon auch
schon ein paar auf wunsch bestellt das
zeige ich euch gleich gerne nochmal
sonst könnt ihr euch ja auch super gerne
das video dazu anschauen weil ich es
schon online ist wo die ausführlich
getestet wurden dann habe ich natürlich
hier einen moment ich will euch mal den
artikel so zeigen ich hoffe den gibt es
noch jetzt so kostet ja nur noch 59 euro
ich habe dafür 68 euro bezahlt ein
iphone el fayed ja steht auch hier
erhält pro face unlock na da bin ich mal
gespannt sieht man auch hier an diesen
drei kameras dass es sich wirklich um
ein iphone
froh dass ganz normale 1 von 11 hat
diese dinger gar nicht mehr
also hat gar nicht diese drei kameras
egal ich hoffe dieses ding hat die drei
kameras wir werden sehen und ja das habe
ich auch bestellt das ist glaube ich das
coolste produkt worauf ich mich auch
sehr freuen
die ganzen sachen werden natürlich
wieder auf beim instagram account
verlost dann habe ich noch folgendes
gemacht ich habe einfach mal macbook
eingegeben und habe mir dann irgendwie
sonst dieses mini dingen hier gezogen
mini ja da ist sogar apple logo drauf
auf der verpackung ich bin mal gespannt
wie das aussieht wenn ich euch das
gleich zeigen werde
und zu guter letzt haben wir noch diese
maus hier ich habe da so eine sowieso in
original und da kann man immer gut auch
nur zweiter gebrauchen die habe ich mir
für acht euro plus 6 euro versand also
insgesamt 14 euro gekauft sogar jetzt
schon ausverkauft wenn man drauf klickt
bin ich auch mal gespannt was da auf
mich zukommt und bevor ich es vergesse
das habe ich auch noch bestellt ein
iphone ladekabel sogar kostenlos na ja
da muss ich sagen das habe ich leider
schon ausgepackt und verwendet einfach
weil ich brauchte weil ich irgendwie
mein kabel in amerika vergessen habe
oder so und ich kann dazu sagen dieses
dingen ist absolut komisch manchmal
verliert man sogar prozent wenn man
damit lädt obwohl das steht da es wird
aufgeladen kann ich euch auch vielleicht
später mal zeigen oder es liegt ganz
normal
da gibt es zwei verschiedene
möglichkeiten das sind die sachen wir
packen jetzt aus ich wünsche euch viel
spaß mit den kanal lass mir gerne nach
oben dafür weitere solche videos und
let's go so leute herzlich willkommen
zurück
hier liegen fünf wunderschöne pakete hey
wieso stiche 11 23
soll ich noch mal anrufen wir gucken wir
dran geht viel spaß ich würde sagen will
aber nicht lang nicht starten direkt bin
gespannt
ich fange man hier mit der 112 an was
auch immer das sein
ach so julius übrigens heute auch wieder
dabei der war auch ein bruder plan war
gut
wieso musste jedes mal sagen ich war im
urlaub
ich mache die ganze zeit wurde du hast
das letzte halbe jahr urlaub gemacht und
zwar ich habe ja noch gar nicht genau
gesagt was ich alles bestellt habe also
es geht um apple produkte
hier haben wir eine paypal watch sieht
diese aus wie eine originale schon gut
sondern gut an
die habe ich geschossen für 18 euro habe
ich die gekauft um einfach nur ein
bisschen aufzuflexen ich habe jetzt das
eingesehen der mit fake erfolgs gepflegt
hat wo war das am flughafen st stücke
boa hat vibriert so okay ich habe es
jetzt gerade an gemacht ich muss sagen
ich habe keine richtige oder originale
apple watch da gibt es nur vier sprachen
englisch an jedoch nicht es gibt alle
sprachen wir nehmen deutsch über die
apple icons hecht ja ja also das ist auf
jeden fall
ich ziehe man die folie ab aber würdest
du jetzt direkt erkennen dass es fähig
ist
ich weiß nicht willig sind
dieses irgendwie gut oder wenn sie jetzt
noch funktioniert aber ich kann hier so
hin und herschwanken also der erste
eindruck ist mega ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern das ist ungefähr zwei
jahre her da habe ich ein video gemacht
wo ich eine smart watch bayerisch
bestellt habe die wir im gegensatz
hierzu die war ungefähr gleich teuer ein
absoluter reinfall also konntest du
direkt eigentlich auch müll schmeißen
die hier ist schon da ist die h ist
keyboard die uhr
okay ich bin schon connected das heißt
ich kann jetzt hier acht mein puls
gemessen so leute ich hab jetzt mal um
ein handgelenk messen mal kurz den puls
ob das funktioniert das werk also 77
beats per minute zwei könnte das passen
ein bisschen nicht ganz ich glaube dass
ein bisschen niedrig sollte also ich
muss sagen ich natürlich könnte ich mich
jetzt damit weiter auseinander setzen
jetzt habe ich ja das kommt schon eher
hin glaub ich ja also ich könnte jetzt
natürlich noch weitere funktionen
ermitteln das ist ja ganz klar
ich weiß noch nicht ob das jetzt so sinn
macht für dieses video oder ob wir das
halt dann vielleicht mal einen extra
video machen sollten weil das geht sonst
ewig werden wir noch genug sachen werden
ob das handy und so deswegen also hier
warte mal sind die kontakte
synchronisiert kannst du denn
telefonieren dirk luckow ich muss sagen
der touch ist auch wirklich gut das
funktioniert echt nice sag mal denn nur
ich gebe das raus 0 1 mein okay leute
ich habe jetzt mal julis nummern geräte
wie das anrufen kann ich ja ich kann
über die watch hallo
das funktioniert recht gut weil ich ja
hallo hallo du hörst mich auf der bühne
hallo also ich muss sagen ich hätte
nicht gedacht ist es so dass diese
features wirklich so gut funktionieren
also ich bin jetzt kein experte auf
diesem gebiet was smartphones angeht
müsste ich mich noch ein bisschen weiter
beschäftigen wenn ihr sagt macht gern
mal ein ganzes wieder zu lasten daumen
nach oben oder schreibt in die
kommentare
ich lasse ich einfach mal dran oder
reflexen vielleicht genau machen weiter
und zwar juni pass auf ich habe auch
bestellt ein macbook mini macbook
nämlich mehr uhr bog er mit apple
originale originale logo andere modell
aber original hätte der abfüll nicht
reingebissen hat mich zwei euro kostet
das war glaube ich das günstigste aber
das realistisch sein und deswegen habe
ich mitgenommen
und hier haben wir doch dann direkt
schon das gros hatte nicht mal die mitte
getroffen
das stimmt weißt du was das ist ein
schminkspiegel kann ich marie schenken
und hier steht sogar noch macbook air
fragt sich nur wie man das am besten
aufgestellt wo sie abziehen also ich
muss sagen ist auf jeden fall kreativ
kann ich jetzt nicht viel mit anfang
also auf jeden fall deutlich weniger als
brot für mich jetzt sehen deutlich
weniger als mit der uhr aber leistung
hat vielleicht ein cooles quatsch
geschenk für mädels so ich verliere
durch das gerne in der video
beschreibung check das ab genau
übrigens ich stehe ja auch mehr durch in
kontakt und ich habe gehört ich kriege
für eventuell schon dieses video aber
ich denke mal weil die noch nicht
geantwortet haben wenn beim nächsten mit
video kriege ich nicht weil die ich an
euch verlosen kann und auch rabatt kurz
ich glaube 5 50 euro gutschein das sogar
5 30 euro scheine
deswegen freue mich aufs nächste video
und wir machen weiter durch das handy
machen als nächstes unter die erst zum
schluss wir machen erstmal bin ich auch
sterben auf raten was hier in potsdam
sind keine airports in st
[Musik]
bei der eingehenden der akku leer ist
die zweite täterin ist gut dass jetzt
nur zwei tagen kommt mir das nur so vor
oder ist die dunkler als ok mac direkt
schon dass sie absolut fähig ist da
müssen sogar batterien rein oder was ist
das denn
ich glaube dass das musst du bei meiner
alten aus aber das soll ja eine neue
sein
das hatte ich ja immer nur diese fakten
batterie jetzt muss ich erst wieder
bakterien suchen wartet manchmal mal
kurz was vergleichen
also ich würde mal sagen von der form
her ist das eins zu eins gleich die hier
ist halt irgendwie dunkler und da fehlt
auch das apple logo aber man weiß schon
was er meinte
die frage ist jetzt nur ob sie
funktioniert schon mal kurz eine
batterie aus meiner ferne
das bringt dir auf jeden fall schon aber
die ganze ausklingen lässt sich nicht
die müsste doch eigentlich leuchten oder
mainz ii batterie leute ich habe jetzt
eine batterie rein getan die safe voll
ist aber die wird nicht also die blinkt
zwischendurch mal ganz kurz da ist auch
immer ist lose drin
ich glaube dieses defekt oder so also
ich kriege keine verbindung hergestellt
das ist sehr sehr komisch kann man das
hören das klingt gar nicht gut ja keine
ahnung ist schrott dann werde ich direkt
mal hier melden damit ich mein geld
gekriegt das geht mich eigentlich
naja aber sehe ich denn hier airports ja
ja das sind die frau die mich auch
nochmal kurz zeigen man kommt airport
groß wir haben airport broß mein neuer
kanal der ist in machen leute genau
diese airports pro sind von bush die
habe ich irgendwann letztens mal
bestellt ich glaube die waren sogar
relativ günstig irgendwie meistens noch
da haben wir auf jeden fall schon wieder
zugemacht irgendwas um 30 oder 40 euro
also in ordnung die waren auch gut ich
habe mich schon getestet also für das
geld kann ich die euch auf jeden fall
empfehlen falls ihr das ganze video
sehen wollt indem wir die ausführlich
getestet haben war linke ich sehr gerne
in der
die beschreibung oder am ende deswegen
will ich dazu jetzt gar nicht mehr so
viel sagen ist auf jeden fall auf
neuestes produkt und wir kommen jetzt
zum letzten produkt und das ist das
iphone app da bin ich mal gespannt ob
ich habe eben schon gemerkt ich habe
vergessen ein ipad zu bestellt oder ein
ipad fake ist ein bisschen schade mangel
vielleicht beim nächsten mal also wenn
ihr das wollt schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
verpackungen sind aber cool
das war freis und drei gleichzeitig zu
lassen
also hält auch viel kühlwasser ok dann
lasst mir das okay
hier würde ich euch das habe ich schon
gesehen was das bedeuten soll weiß ich
noch nicht so ganz weil ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass das wohnheim 20
gigabyte hat oder 820 128 gbyte
wahrscheinlich ist dass eine sd karte
die man hinzufügen können bis zu 100 bis
zu 128 gb so verpackung ist natürlich
ähnlich wie beim iphone nur ohne druck
drauf und hier haben wir dann auch schon
das gerät ladekabel kopfhörer
schade wir haben keinen lightning kabel
da hätte ich mich sehr darüber gefreut
aber ich habe es mir auch schon gedacht
muss ich sagen oh wow
die haben sich hier nicht lumpen lassen
sonst noch eine nette wille dazu
geschickt weißt du was das ding ist für
diese hülle hätte ich im saturn jetzt
wieder 30 euro wird wahrscheinlich ich
habe letztens ein video gemacht da habe
ich iphone cases vorgestellt das auf
jeden fall sehr gerne ab aber ich mich
da ein bisschen drüber aufgeregt und die
auch so ein bisschen mit diesen saturn
media markt verglichen
und hier haben wir jetzt das produkt
auch dass sie wahrscheinlich alle wartet
ich bin mal gespannt
also
das einzige was glaube ich ziemlich
ähnlich ist sind diese drei kameras hier
hinten ist hier auch beim iphone 11 so
oder ich glaube nur beim iphone 11
bericht ich da bin ich ein bisschen
überfragt wenn jetzt auch kein experte
auf diesem gebiet maria tonight von 11
die hat nur zwei camps und sonst naja
ich habe es vielleicht ein bisschen
besser
er hofft trotzdem ist es okay für das
geld hier steht halt leider auch oder
was heißt leider ist natürlich an sich
auch besser aber wenn ich solche videos
mache ist natürlich mal lustig wenn es
möglichst nah ans original kommt also
wir hatten auf jeden fall schon bessere
iphone fakes in diesen formaten kann ich
mich daran erinnern allerdings noch nie
nen iphone 11 weg deswegen machen wir
das jetzt mal an weil sie überhaupt
angeht was hast du für sozial 70 euro
und natürlich hat das erinnert mich an
meine alte htc von vor zehn jahren oder
so was ist das bitte sein sowas wellkamp
das ist mit das ist youtube design
dieses mit schatten nach unten weise wie
vor von zehn jahren oder so
wir haben aber sogar diese original gar
die apple icons das ist super nice
youtube ist schon drauf whatsapp auch
jeder zieht an sie also dass da freu
mich jetzt drüber
guck mal ein youtube video von mir
vielleicht okay also jetzt auf jeden
fall android drauf nur mit denen apple
icons ne was mir aufgefallen dass wir
versuchen jetzt mal youtube-video zu
schauen und es war mir wurde gerade am
anfang gar nicht gefragt welche sprache
wie eigentlich haben wollen wie ich
heiße ob ich irgendwie eine sim-karte
einfügen möchte oder sowie das alt
eigentlich sonst der fall ist neues
reaktionswege auch alex baur schauen wir
uns an einem neuen kanal alle abonnieren
statt
ja ich was geht ab und damit herz mit
kopf zurück auf dem wahrscheinlich nicht
besten reaktion des kanal auf ganz
youtube aber es wird immer besser
wir haben ein stuhl und ein vernünftiges
mikrofone ich hier was ist das
eigentlich habe ich dort ausgeharrt
haben sie ein guter grund laufen auch
das so gewollt ist ist die frage
also ich würde mal sagen mit der
berücksichtigung dass es halt nur 70
euro gekostet hat ist es solides gerät
es hat sicherlich den einen oder anderen
fehler und ist nicht immer also reagiert
nicht perfekt aber es ist okay wenn ich
jetzt an handys denke die es zum
beispiel bei media markt gibt oder so
die 150 euro kosten
da kann hat auf jeden fall mithalten
deswegen würde ich auch hier sagen wenn
das eben mal von euch haben will checkt
man gern mein instagram ab da ist jetzt
ne story und meine ich muss sowieso noch
soviel verlosen wir noch ganz viele
cases für verschiedenste handys und so
also das wird alles noch bei insidern
durchgeführt auch hier die comco
vielleicht behalte ich die sogar selber
ich weiß es nicht da gibt es ja
vielleicht auch noch ein extra wieder zu
dann würde ich sagen wir sind eigentlich
schon am ende
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen das war
bestimmt ein etwas längeres video hat
mir spaß gemacht und freut euch auf das
nächste video
da werden wir iphone 11 gadgets
vorstellen dass wir glaube ich auch
ziemlich interessant da gibt es dann
hoffentlich auch die gutscheincodes
vielleicht ist hier in der video
beschreibung auch schon ein
gutscheincode checkt das auf jeden fall
sehr genau ab ging's am alex abonniert
meinen zweikanal gerne auf diesem kanal
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder gibt's
neues video
haut rein